we've talked about how this is a book
that is designed or the the idea behind
principles is designed not for people to
mimic your own but for them to come up
with their own principles so I'd love to
understand what are the principles that
people really react to and have there
been any that you've heard from others
that have surprised you or you know that
you have said like more people should be
hearing about this
um the book is really intended to deal
with the subject of having principles
principles are ways of dealing with the
realities that you encounter that work
so every successful person has
principles that work they have their
formulas for success
and then it passes along my own
principles those those formulas for
success and so as far as the reactions
go
um many people have come up to me and
said it's changed my life thank you very
very much
um and then
um you know what are the most important
principles that it's an approach to life
like one principle is pain plus
reflection equals progress
uh it explains the ideas of getting a
truth what is true getting past egos
getting open-mindedness how you yourself
don't have to have all the answers if
you can do that how you can draw it in
what the life cycle is like it's a bunch
of things like that and um and then
it uh encourages people to
um write down their own principles uh
it's a it's a different way of thinking
than this principled way of thinking
when you start to think in that way you
realize everything happens over and over
again
for the same reasons almost you know if
you're a parent that you're not the
first time to be a parent
and then you can look at principles of
how to do that well so um you know for
that reason also I'm encouraging other
people to do that